hi everyone welcome to this evening's
reconvened meeting of traffic council
planning and development management
committee
my name is aidan williams and i'm the
chair of the committee the vice chair is
councillor ben hartley
also presented this virtual meeting of
offices from the council's planning
department
legal services democratic services and
the local highway authority
as well as the elected members who make
up the committee
as the meeting is reconvened we'll
proceed straight to business but before
we do so
i should remind those president for that
information that this meeting is being
live streamed and recorded so please
mute your microphones
to minimize background noise if you wish
to speak to an item
please use the chat facility to notify
me of your intention to do so
and then wait until i invite you to
speak
um counselor i'm aware that you've
already declared
an interest at the the previous meeting
what i just remind members of is that if
they do have an
interest to declare to do so before the
item
um on the agenda is is handled
so we'll move to the applications for
consideration
this evening the first one that we'll
look at is 19 blueberry
road which you can find on page 186 of
the committee report
and before we hear from any other
speakers there will be an office of
introduction from
ms coaly thank you chairman i'll just
share my screen if
members just bear with me
[Music]
can people see the presentation on the
screen
yeah good okay thank you um this
application is at 19 blueberry road in
bowdoin and it's
a um variation to a previous application
that that members
considered it a few months ago it's
reported to the committee
because there have been six objections
received contrary to the
officer recommendation you can see the
site there on the north northern side of
blueberry road and it's currently
occupied by a single dwelling
so this is a variation of condition
application following the ground to the
previous application for the erection of
a pair of semi-detached dwellings
and has immensely approved plans to vary
the external design of the properties
the site is currently occupied by a
detached mid-20th century dwelling
and is bound by residential properties
to all sides with the public
right-of-way running along its side
western boundary which you can see with
my cursor there
so um this is the proposed site plan the
green
line shows the outline of the existing
dwelling on the site
you can see that the plot is divided
into two
uh each with its own own garden two
semi-detached properties in each with
parking at the front um these are the
proposed
front side
hope elevations i will come on to the
changes between this and the approved
scheme in a moment once i've been
through these slides
rear and side elevations
the ground floor plan again with the
green showing the outline of the
existing dwelling
the first floor plan
and then the loft plan so one of the
main changes to the scheme is the use of
this loft area for living accommodation
previously it was shown
as storage and consequently there would
be an
increase in the roof bridge height by
0.2 of a meter
to 8.13 meters and that's the roof
detail you can see it's a flat roof in
the center
front boundary treatment
and then the street scene elevations
showing the relationship of the property
to the dwellings on either side
cgi's and then a comparison of the
previously
approved scheme and the current scheme
members consider this morning as you can
see the footprint of the of the proposed
development is extremely similar
with the main changes around the roof
sorry
the porches at the front so the front
porch is project slightly further
forward than the previously approved
scheme
which is 7.7 meters um
from the front boundary that's back from
the front boundary as opposed to
just over eight meters from the front
boundary previously
then you can see the difference in the
elevations
the front porch is there and a very
slight increase in the roof ridge height
there otherwise elevationally the the
proposals
are identical so the key issues for
consideration design
residential emergency in highways and
parking impacts
principle of the proposed development of
two dwellings has been established
through the previous grant of planning
commission
and because of the section 73
application the matters to be considered
are limited to the proposed changes to
the approved plans
um officers have considered the
proposals carefully in the objections
raised
and we consider the development will be
acceptably designed not
unacceptably impact on residential
emergency and there will be no
additional impact on
on parking uh the application is
therefore recommended for approval
subject to conditions
thank you chairman i will stop sharing
now
thank you ms kowali um at the previous
committee meeting we have been advised
that i think council of churchill
intended to speak
against the application however would
not be able to
make the meeting itself and as such a
written statement will be read out
and if that's still the case please yes
mrs lowes will read that out thank you
thank you to a written statement
by um councillor churchill against the
planning application at 19 blue brew
road
i'd like to thank the committee for
giving me the opportunity to provide my
comments
in support of the objections to this
application unfortunately i am unable to
attend in person
the application is to vary the condition
around the approved plans for the site
at 19 blueberry road in bowdoin
i represent the residents in their
objections to the application for
the planning permission in august 2020
there are a number of issues with this
application
and i'd like to highlight the main
objections mainly the impact
on the local area and the impact on the
residents of neighbouring properties
blue brew road is a leafy area and is
predominantly characterized by two-story
detached residences
the proposed increase in ridge heights
of the new dwellings the change in
layout
and new windows at loft level would mean
that the dwellings would have three
habitable stories and as such would be
out of keeping with
other properties on this road the
requested variations would further
the impact of the development which is
already larger than the existing
buildings on the street
with two stories being squeezed onto the
size of one house
moreover enlarging the ground floor
footprint and porches of the
development's two houses would further
enlarge the scale
which would become become nearer the
footprint size of the previously
rejected application on this site
the structures will be disproportionate
to the size of the plot in congress to
the area
and have a noticeably negative impact on
the street scene of this road
the second main objection is the impact
upon residents
the immediate negative impact of this
development would be on the immediate
the amenities of the residents of
blueberry road
with the conversion of the loft space
from storage to living areas
there would clearly be an increased
capacity for more occupants of the two
new dwellings
there this is therefore a serious
concern that parking spaces for such a
development
would be likely to be insufficient
within a short space of time
with the proposed driveways and parking
areas relatively small
and difficult to the point of
impractical for the maneuvering of
multiple cars
this would likely result in additional
street parking in a relatively narrow
street
street which could impact on safety
especially since the development is also
situated on a bend in the road
this is also adjacent to a footpath
crossing
as such it would be likely to result in
more on-road and pavement parking
that would cause a hazard for both
residents and motor vehicle traffic
the impact to neighbouring properties in
terms of privacy
of side-facing windows and terraces also
cannot be underestimated
in slurry this application will cause
harm to the character and street scene
of blueberry road
and the amenity of its residents i
therefore ask the committee to protect
the character and residents of blue brew
road and reject this application
thank you
thank you ms lowe's and i understand
councillor morgan
indicated happy to open discussion
uh thank you chair um this is i think a
relatively
um minor objection though i do uh
appreciate councillor churchill's
comments um
and i do understand the concerns that
the residents have got on this
application though it is an amendment
from the previous application so i think
under planning we have to kind of take
into consideration
um and i do think a lot of the
issues which both of churchill as well
as the
neighbors have raised i think are really
relevant
yeah sorry turn to the democratic
services just highlighted that
there is a speaker against i'm sorry
that's that's my name
no problem um mr young yes thank you
thank you mr chairman yes
sorry about it that's okay shall i go
ahead yeah
you have three minutes to speak if you
do overwhelm i'll just
politely request that you um wrap up
your remarks thank you
right mr mr chairman i'd like to thank
you for the opportunity to address the
committee on this application
for the variation of planning permission
i live next door at 70 in blueberry road
and speaking on behalf
of a number of local residents
originally there were 23 letters
of concern from the occupiers over the
original planning application of further
six letters have been received in
relation to the amended plans
the original permission was given in
august 2020
after withdrawal of earlier plans a long
process of discussion between the
developers and planning officers
to reduce the size and scope of the
development to a level that might be
acceptable to
the committee in the event permission
was given by a majority vote
although a number of members who voted
in favor stated that they were doing so
reluctantly
a major matter of concern with the
original application was the limited
parking spaces
blueberry road is only six metres wide
because of the narrowness of the road
visitors that can't be accommodated on
the driveways tend to park on the
pavement
forcing pedestrians dangerously out into
the road
the government is currently looking at
making this illegal throughout england
our main issues of concern are the
following
the original permission was given for a
property classified
for properties classified as
three-bedroom semis with loft space on
the top floor
in my submission to the committee in
august i pointed out this loft space
would most likely be developed into
additional bedrooms thereby
exacerbating parking requirements this
present request is now to raise the
roofs
and develop this loft space which could
give up to three extra bedrooms in each
residence
moreover request is made to increase the
size of the front porches
that will reduce parking space further
the plans show three very small cars
less than three
four meters long squeezed onto the hard
standing space in front of the houses
this is just completely unrealistic suvs
are well over five meters long
in practice no more than two vehicles
could be accommodated
the residents will park their large cars
on the dangerous bend in the road as
would any visitors
when the original permission was given
it was for three semi-detached houses
on the assumption parking would only be
needed for two cars
now that each house could have five or
six bedrooms it clears
it's clear that the parking space will
well below that required for the
additional residents
the planning committee voted in favor
the original proposal in good faith
after the plans have been trimmed to a
level to allow them to be
passed the local residents now see this
as a cynical venture
to use a backdoor route to maximize
profitability the development
at the expense of lighting neighboring
properties and risking highway safety
we hope that committee members will vote
against these amended plans
particularly those who gave the
developers the benefit of the doubt
and voted reluctantly for the original
proposal thank you
thank you mr young for your contribution
um counselor morgan you want to pick
back up for you
ms coley's indicated to provide some
clarification sorry
yes if i could please chairman uh just
in relation to the parking
uh the additional accommodation in the
loft makes that makes no difference to
the council's parking standards
in this case so the the requirement of
three parking spaces
it would be the case with the three bed
three bedroom dwelling or more it is the
maximum amount that we would seek on any
on any scheme for a residential dwelling
thank you
thank you ms coley um councillor morgan
again if you wanted to continue
no problem chair i thank uh mr um for
those comments but it does kind of
it doesn't change in terms of uh what i
was originally going to say you know
that actually um the a lot of the
arguments against it are against the
original application
now i reluctantly vote in favor of these
back in a few months ago
it doesn't seem that long ago um and
um those comments i did take on board
and i didn't particularly like this
application but i don't think there was
any objection on planning grounds
and i don't think based on the previous
application to this application
that um i have any reason to object on
planning grounds alone though i don't
particularly like the the squeezing on
this property and i do think it is
it isn't in keeping with the previous
property but i would just like to say
chair
i really do understand why both council
churchill has raised this
as has mr young i really do hate this
way of this is the third time i've been
on this planning committee for just
under eight
just over 18 months and it's the third
time i've seen this
application and i really do dislike
this way that we have have creeping
applications do what i mean and i can
imagine how much
council taxpayers money has been spent
in the fact that rather than getting
one application we've had to have three
applications um
utilizing valuable planning times our
time
as councillors and i know i'm probably
utilizing that time in a few seconds
the committee but i really do just want
to put on record that i really don't
like the fact that
this is creeping up and i really don't
want to have to see that this property
on the um
um yet again when another slight
amendment is made
thank you thank you councillor
councillor
hardly you've also indicated in the
chatted legacy
thank you chair i think i think actually
council morgan's probably covered most
of what i wanted to say i think the
the variation of the condition on this
application um doesn't make a huge
difference so i think
as as he said really a lot of the
objections were to the original
application and
and there aren't there aren't extensive
changes
um i don't think the street scene is
affected by those changes raising the
roof
by 20 centimeters and the um the new
windows that are introduced to the front
and the rear and the
um placing the properties further
forward with
uh with with bigger porches none of
those things really affect the street
scene
in my view the parking has been uh
covered by
miss gurley's advice i suppose what i
would the only thing i was going to say
which which
sort of touches on councillor morgan's
point really was uh you know i agree
about the
the tenancy we're seeing for sort of
creeping applications and we've seen
quite a few applications
to um where plans have been amended to
make the loft space into habitable rooms
that's understandable in a way to be
honest because you know people
will want to get get the most habitable
habitable
accommodate accommodation that they can
out of a plot and
you know it creates high identity
housing to to an extent in that it could
accommodate
more people but i do have a concern that
you know when that's being done by
raising the um the rich height of the
roof then
that that i think can cause a planning
concern i don't think it does here
because it's only 20 centimeters so
probably not noticeable to be honest but
you do see
examples of houses around trafford where
you know the roof
is substantially higher than the houses
around so i think
that there's no reason to object to this
application on planning ground so i've
been minded to
to move that we um that we accept the
officer recommendation to grant
but i i do think angela morgan has a
point really about sort of keeping a
watching brief on
these sorts of applications that we get
thank you chair
thank you councillor any other members
looking to speak to this application
okay
counselor minutes
thank you chair um i was having a look
at so i'm trying to look at uh obviously
the footprint looks quite largely the
same um i'm not i'm not a fan of quite
how the um
built the it's got obviously larger at
the back um
and is i don't know if it's a building
line but that's already been approved in
a previous application anyway
and it's the porch part that's changing
here um
and the and the ridge height so with the
with the height of the roof
there's a couple of questions i had with
it but and i wanted to know if it was in
keeping with um
properties along the road so uh one was
about the obviously where it's got a
flat roof part
um i'm assuming the height is going up
so that you could you actually have the
correct head height
in the loft space to have it to class
them as bedrooms
but there's a proposed that it says that
there was a previously appreciated one
of the many previous applications
had the the same roof height and it was
uh rejected or withdrawn um so i just
wanted to know
is this is this red ridge is this new
height for this application the same and
if so why
why is it now okay but wasn't okay
before if i can just
have a quick answer for that that'd be
great
i would need to check back on that um
counsellor i believe
i believe it it it may be the same i'll
double check
i think the issue with the previous
application was not just the roof height
there were there were very many other
concerns
with it which have now been resolved um
but if you just bear with me i will
check
thank you be your your hand is up
yes thanks chad um like colleagues
you know i i've got my thoughts on on
this
original application and this
application
and i wouldn't like mr young to go away
and think we've not given it or i've not
given it
great consideration but um i've been
i've looked at the premises
and and i read the report several times
and i have to be honest with myself
there's no clear reasons that i can find
to refuse
thank you councillor council accordingly
you've indicated in the chat that
you're happy to second the application
you need to confirm that and
make any comments if you wish yeah i'm
happy to uh
uh second uh councillor hartley's uh
proposal if you
if you like i endorse everything you've
said i don't think i need to repeat
thanks thank you council but just whilst
ms coley is clarifying um
the the information relating to council
administer this question i just thought
i'd
sort of put my own thinking on the
record i can absolutely share the
sentiments that have been expressed by
council hartley
um and also by councillor morgan that it
must be
extremely frustrating for residents who
have concerns about applications such as
this in that in their neighborhoods
to see that the application keeps coming
back to committee to have minor
amendments that sort of creeping process
the council of the morgan
um referred to so i i can understand and
i have every sympathy with
mr young and with other concerned
residents one thing i did want to say is
i i agree with
what we heard in the office introduction
that it is only a minor amendment it is
a small change to the previously
approved application and it seems quite
clear officers have commented on this in
the report that
the applicant has listened to feedback
and did reduce the main ridge heights
and in respect of the other objections i
actually this this was a comprehensive
report i read through paragraph 42 to 51
and it seemed to me that the objections
were
addressed quite methodically and on that
basis i don't think i myself can find
a reason um to refuse permission this
evening
in spite of the the huge amount of
history that i think um
this application carries so that's my
thinking and i think i will be
supporting
the office of recommendation this
evening now i think ms coley has
provided
has managed to find the information that
council minister is
looking for thank you i have i've had
clarification
that the uh proposed ridge height in the
current
application is not as high as the
previously withdrawn scheme
uh thank you scalia that's that's great
um
the is the is the flat roof the same as
what
neighboring properties have as well that
was my other my other bit sorry
um i wouldn't know without checking
google earth i suspect not if they're
traditional properties
yeah there are other properties in the
vicinity which do have this flat roof
approach so quite a d
is to allow the the depth of the
building without the roof ridge being it
being extremely high which it would be
if it continued all the way it was quite
common
in the area okay thank you thank you
very much
thank you ms coleman councilman um the
application has now been proposed and
seconded
um that we grant permission in line with
officer recommendation if there's
anybody
with a really burning desire to speak if
you just let us know now but otherwise
i'm inclined to move to the room
okay i'll just run three members as
you're appearing in my screen there's no
particular order but um
counselor proctor if you can confirm
your vote please
agree with councillor officer
recommendation to grant
thank you council council would you
rather
vote in line with officer recommendation
to grant thanksgiving
thank you councillor councillor rigby i
agree with the officer's recommendation
too
grant thank you councillor councillor
hartley
thank you chair i agree with the officer
recommendation to grant thank you thank
you councillor councilman minis
um i'm not a fan of the creeping nature
but i can't see a reason to say
no so uh begrudgingly going with a
council recommendation to grant thank
you
thank you councillor councillor morgan
um thank you chair like councilmanist
begrudgingly agree with
officer recommendations thank you
councillor councillor win stanley uh
continuing the team chair thank you
be gradually in line with officer
recommendations
thank you councillor council accordingly
uh a support officer's recommendation to
grant
thank you councillor and councillor
holden are you here
in your capacity to speak to the other
application no no
i'm here as a substitute as well so i
vote to
accept the recommendation and grant
this application thank you councillor
and
i will also be supporting uh officer
recommendation this evening so that
application is approved
i understand the vote was unanimous
thank you
and the next application we'll turn to
is harry lord house which you can find
on page 119
of the committee report um before we
hear from anyone else
the application is going to be
introduced again by ms coleman
okay are you able to hear me now yeah
that's great thank you okay
no problem um you can see harry lord
house here on the on the slide
it's position opposite halal park uh on
the
uh and uh facing northumberland road
it's um its previous uh authorized use
was as a care home
uh but currently it is in an
unauthorized
uh house in multiple occupation
this application is an outline
application for layout scale
appearance um and with only landscaping
as a reserve matter so it's pretty much
a full application
in in all but but name we would only see
a landscaping scheme come forward in a
reserved matter
and that's for the conversion of the
building into 66 studio student
apartments um the application has been
referred to committee as more than six
objections have been received i'll take
you through some of the plans now
so this is these are the street scene
elevations we've got
humphrey road elevation see the property
there with the uh
traditional um old trafford uh
semis and terraces there there that's
the proposed and this is the existing
that's the side elevation effectively
facing northumberland road again with
um other flatter developments either
side
these are the other two elevations you
can see the single story
element at the back of the um property
which exists
and again they're proposed and existing
ground floor plans
so you can see the porch extension at
the front there
first floor again that shows you can see
the porch extension
second and the upper upper room
each of these um here are the dormers
you can see coming out of the roof
and then there's a site plan so you can
see the parking area here
one accessible parking space there a
drop off there i think
i think at the current time there's a
disabled parking space uh marked out
there
bike store and then there's a
surrounding immunity space
and there's some photos of the site and
surroundings
okay i'll just take you back to the
layout and uh go through the rest of the
introduction so the development is for
student specific housing and there's
that there would be a condition if
members of minded to approve which would
which would limit
the accommodation to uh to students
and it would be in assist in what office
is considered as a sustainable location
close to local services and
public transport uh a management plan
has been provided and again would be
secured by condition
which was details how the apartment
block would be managed
in terms of minimising potential for
disruption and also in terms of a travel
plan
and car parking uh we've considered the
extension alterations they're considered
acceptable both in visual
and residential amenity terms you know
the building is what it is
so um you know you're not going to have
very fundamental changes to the
the appearance of the building um and
the
landscaping could would be dealt with at
uh reserve matters but
we're confident that there are
sufficient trees and another
uh soft landscaping around the site that
that would provide an
appropriate environment um consider the
room sizes
carefully we don't have any particular
student accommodation
policy in trafford either in the local
planner in the spd beyond
our spd on housing multiple occupation
because
because we've not needed one um but
we've had a look at
camden's student housing policy as a as
a reasonable comparator and the size of
the rooms
uh would comply with that there's also
uh
quite a few shared amenities on the
ground floor which which
uh would be available to the to the
residents
um student car parking would actually be
prevented on site so the parking would
be for the staff there would be 13 staff
at a one to five ratio
uh 10 10 during the day and and three at
night including security
so and the
students would be prevented from
bringing a car to the premises or
parking a car on
surrounding streets as part of the
tennessee agreement
um the exception would to that would be
anybody who required an accessible
space as as as one is is provided so if
a student required that space and they
would obviously be able to use it
uh and on that matter there is one uh
accessible room for a wheelchair
provided
um and other rooms on the ground floor
could be adapted to be wheelchair
accessible if necessary um we've
considered all all the issues um
and on balance it is recommended
for approval it's not
it it is what it is really it
it's i think if it was an entirely new
development we'd be seeking a higher
level of design but it isn't it's a
conversion of an existing building
so as it stands um it is recommended for
approval thank you chairman
thank you ms coley um i think there's
only one person speaking
it's this i understand councillor john
had indicated he'd like to
speak on behalf of president
chair i don't think um council jarman is
available at the moment he's in
a other council meeting so he's provided
a written statement for me to read on
his behalf
thank you for allowing me to speak and
i'm sure i won't need the full five
minutes
this particular application has been
triggering on for the best part of six
months
we started getting representations on
this from early
in september and well into november i
was first made aware of it by the
clifford wall councillors who had
received many representations from their
residents
the site is on the clifford longfit
border and right at the heart of the old
trafford community
the longford councillors then started to
get many representations from residents
on our side of the ward boundary as word
had got around by a social media
and old-fashioned word of mouth it has
to be said
that there was a lot of dissatisf
dissatisfaction
about the consultation process of the
perception was that it was not
as far as it should or might have been
for such a major development
covert restrictions were obviously a
major factor and the view was that more
allowance should have been given
i'm pleased to see is now being given
further consideration
but i'm not clear if the public have
been further consulted
so there were a lot of points made by
the members of the public some not
relevant in planning terms or not good
enough for reasons for refusal
there were a few stereotypes about
student lifestyles and potential
conflict with the rest of the community
it is a view but not one i am going to
subscribe to
however there are some very relevant
observations made by members of the
public
the proposed development does not does
not do anything for local planning
systems
[Music]
and
make it viable giving alternative given
alternative choices it is also doubtful
what effect ua 92
would have on it as it has had an
uncertain start
not helped by covid pandemic and most of
the students so far have come from
the local area the application may
depend
on attracting overseas students or from
other parts of the uk
there's been a lot of concern about the
lack of parking with only 10 spaces
available for 66 units
i think in the report estimates that
only two percent of the student
population drive a car
this estimate seems consideration should
also be given to visitors
and parents dropping off or picking up
of their offspring at the start and
finish of each term
there was very little off street parking
around the site with very narrow streets
and vehicles parking on both sides
i would therefore conclude that the
local community would prefer to see a
modestly sized development of family and
single person
apartments and housing with a high
degree of affordability
it would be a wasted opportunity not to
attract a high quality housing
development on this site
thank you for allowing me to speak
thank you um a number of members have
indicated in the chat that they'd like
to contribute to the discussion
council accordingly um thanks chair
yeah it's it's difficult oneness in some
ways because i understand
um um
that we are going to get more student
accommodation within trafford it is
going to be a growing thing not
necessarily uh
just connected with ua 92 actually this
location
is equal distance to manchester met it's
uh
it's not i mean we're almost jumping the
gun there
but nevertheless i think uh the old
trafford area
is going to be an area which does
attract student accommodation
um and it it's clear
we almost admitted that we're not really
ready for that into in terms of planning
rules and what have you so we're almost
being caught
a little bit unaware but i think uh the
comparison we can
camden is a good one and essentially
this is student accommodation that's
been um
applied for it's in this it's not in the
worst
position to provide that as a at the end
of a road
uh i do worry about the rule that
prevents students from having cars
in the residential roads i can see why
we could stop them
but i don't see how we can stop your
students having a car
that just seems that seems a little bit
too far for me
um but having said that i i am in
support of this application because i
think
uh there's no reason to stop it but i am
worried that we're not really ready for
um all the the
the issues the one thing i would really
like is that almost the condition
on sort of community liaison from the
owners
of that with council the local
councillors
um i don't know if that's an issue but
um
that we can do but i would like
i wouldn't like this to be built and
imposed and not have local
uh records um not a local liaison
in there and i'd almost like to have
that as a condition
and i i i'm happy to propose
thank you counselor um i think members
are sort of
i experienced a very brief interruption
to um
councillor jarman's representation that
joined ms milner's um
reading it out and i think a few people
have said as much in the
chat um are we happy just to run over
the prep what was contained in that
paragraph possibly
yeah you just bear with me
helen it cut from um after some
very relevant observations made by a
member of the
public um and the next the two bullet
points from the proposed development
uh all the way down to um to
uh the sentence about ua 92
was uh wasn't heard okay so the first
paragraph was missing
and and part of the second one the next
thing i heard was this application may
depend upon attracting
overseas students right i'll read the
first paragraph again then hopefully it
won't drop out apologies
and so the first paragraph said the
proposed development
does not do anything for local planning
sustainability
student residence would be an
overwhelmingly transient community
it'd be good to promote a more
sustainable outcome for this site
with a mix of single and affordable
family housing
there was a question as to whether this
particular locality would attract enough
students to make it viable
given alternative choices it is also
doubtful
what effect ua 92 would have on it as it
has an
uncertain start not helped by the kobit
pandemic
and most students so far have come from
the local area
this application may depend on
attracting overseas students or others
from other parts of the uk it was was
that clear
yeah i got all that yeah thank you
thank you um councillor harvey uh thank
you chair
i'm i'm happy to second councillors
accordingly to
to move that we uh agree the the officer
recommendation to to grant on this one
um
i am i think it's a good use of the
existing building
uh you know the design isn't amazing but
um i think as miss coley said it's an
existing building and i think actually
the um the sort of rendering and and the
works that are going to go onto the
exterior probably make the building more
attractive it's quite a
you know you don't really notice the
building when you when you go past on
northumberland road
uh as i do sometimes you just don't
notice it at all so i think i think
actually the
the changes that are that are indicated
on the appearance will um
will make it more attractive in the
street scene um
the development does contribute to the
housing need for students and
cancer accordingly covered this really
we do need to address that and we do
need student accommodation
um it is obviously student
student populations are transient
populations but we still
have to meet a housing need for that for
that population
and i actually think it's better to do
it in this way and have managed
accommodation
like this because the report describes
well in
paragraph five i think it is the
alternative which is that if we
if we don't approve schemes for managed
accommodation then
um you will end up with existing housing
stock being converted into
into student flats and residencies which
i think probably has a
potentially has a you know more of an
impact on on the local area and on on
neighbours
um i think the uh
the the room size sort of concerning
when i first read the report the rooms
do
seem small uh i can't see anything on
the plans about
communal kitchens although there are
some communal areas
but you know have in mind that um this
reference made to the
to the guidelines in camden that the
studios are
do are adequately sized so i think that
is probably fine
um the two more things really one is i
queried in my mind whether
one accessible room is sufficient though
i think i think miss colleen advice said
there was potential to convert
some of the other rooms which which i i
hadn't noticed in the report so i think
if that's the case then
then that is is probably fine also my
last
point was just about the um the cycle
storage
um so i agree with the report
recommending that it should be
one-to-one secure cycle spaces for each
each studio the condition uh
is condition eight which requires the
development not to be occupied until the
scheme for
cycle storage spaces has been submitted
and approved
i'm i'm sort of aware that that student
accommodation can be a real target for
um
for theft of cycles that is that is an
issue really so
i i think it would be inadequate if
there were simply a number of
sheffield stands at the back of the
accommodation um
i think that would still be a target for
crime really so
i wonder if that condition could be more
around
ensuring that there's um you know a
lockable uh
a lockable facility i can't think of the
word but you know
a lockable sort of shed where the cycle
storage would be rather than just
um cycle stands that are sort of exposed
to the elements and in view if you like
um so i don't know if we could amend
that condition to provide for that
um but aside from that i'm happy to
second the uh the motion to
a greedy officer recommendation thank
you chair
thank you councillor miss coley um
on oh you've clarified it in the chat
that that's the
intention in the the phrasing of
securing the condition thank you
and counselor minis
i just wanted well parts of um
completely um echo
uh parts of what counselor heartless has
said about the
the cycles i thought that i'm looking on
the picture it wasn't enough
for the number of um of rooms there but
obviously
if that's a condition there and
obviously if it can be secure cycle
storage then that would be
far better um because otherwise bikes
getting nicked is a problem
um i actually quite like a lot i mean so
using of
the existing building i quite like the
idea of having at least
the students in some way sort of in one
area contained
as it were the the rooms being smaller
it's kind of the nature of i guess
student accommodation and
because you kind of have one person in a
room so it's not like
it's not it's a bit different to family
accommodation type things
um i would i would hope i quite i'm
quite excited by some of it i think the
the concerns about say parking is like
like some residents
i can understand about the parking with
um say families coming to collect their
children
uh from university but um they don't
they tend not to all quite arrive at
once i would hope
um so hopefully that won't be as bad i
don't know whether
we is there any option to have the
um permit parking for the residents
nearby
or is that not something that we want to
look at that was what i was going to ask
as well but otherwise i'm quite excited
about it and i'll be
uh voting um in line with officer
recommendation but if you can just
clarify about the is permit parking
required nearby
thank you councilman i'd suspect that's
a separate process to the planning
process but ms corley if you if you're
aware
um it would be we have we have um
previously asked for permit permit
schemes to be extended through
section 106 agreements we wouldn't
consider that would be necessary here to
make the
development acceptable in planning terms
because the intention is that the
parking would only be for staff and
and we've got the conditions requiring
the management plan which would um
which which demonstrate that the tenancy
agreements would prevent students from
um from bringing cars
introducing a permit parking scheme for
a twice
termly uh event of uh drop off and pick
up by parents would be entirely
disproportionate in our view
thank you ms coley and casler proctor
yeah thank you chair i pretty much agree
with what council accordingly
and council hartley have said really um
i don't think they're wonderful plans um
but they're probably
an improvement of what what is there at
the moment
and we do we do need the student
accommodation so
um unfortunately it's in right smack
bang against a lot of residents or other
residential properties so
you know if there's going to be any
impact it is going to be sort of schemes
like this close by and it
is going to impact on the local
residents
my two concerns were particularly the
parking that we've heard about already
i mean it despite all those conditions i
i think the 10 spaces is insufficient
um okay about those the conditions
you're going to attach to that
but um reality is i think you know
proportion of those students
are actually going to have cars so it's
going to have a knock on effect on the
sort of local community and local local
streets nearby
so but is that enough for
us to reject it probably not i think the
probably the
travel plan and the other conditions
probably
um answer that and um
but the conditions enable it to
work as best it can the other one that
there's quite a lot of
play on which is a lot representations
about potential noise
noise aspects as i mentioned obviously
it's very close to other
residential properties but the existing
properties
is there already and it's going to be a
slight increase in the
overall numbers of of people are going
to be living there
and i don't think and make any
assumptions that um
because the students are going to be
more noisy than you know all the
potential residents so
i think that is is a non-starter really
so
those are my two so major concerns but i
think
that they are addressed by the
conditions and what we want to do so
i will be happy to go along with
supporting the application thank you
chair
thank you council councillor winston
uh thank you chair i'm not going to
continue your theme i'm loathed
i love this development on so many
levels
it's it's in the wrong place we need i
know i understand
it's current use but if we're going to
redevelop we need residential property
in this area
i think if you look in paragraph four it
does take some interpretation to say
this is in line with our policy
l2 um and i'm also not convinced about
the arguments that the provision of
student accommodation will result in
uh the growth in less suitable hmos
i am willing to make i have to move
moving on i am willing to make a
judgment on the behaviour of students
and i look at that i look at
all the people on this call who have
been students would you sentence
yourself to live next to you
when you were a student i wouldn't have
said since i wouldn't have sentenced
myself to that next to me when
when i was a student so i've got great
concerns about that
and the parking in the traffic i don't
understand that you can stop
students having cars and even even if
they're not going to use them to go to
college which might be early a mile up
the road
they're going to have cars go to the mmu
halls go to manchester or manchester
university halls to see the amount of
cars that are there i think they'll be
extremely difficult to control
so i have great sympathy with all of the
objections which have been raised by um
by the residents and also by um
counselor jonathan
and if i may return to do another issue
which
we talked about in a previous
development because i wanted i want to
talk again about uh disabled
accessibility and i'll be
i'll be very brief chair briefcare
promise because again it's brilliant
we're talking about this and thanks
again to the officers for
talking about uh accessibility in the uh
additional representations report
but i'll say what i said in the la in
the last meeting we can be much much
stronger on this
i think that as we develop our local
plan within trafford
um and we've seen those policies coming
through now that when we're talking to
developers they will understand that one
of our strategic aims
is um disabled accessibility and
in the conversations that we have with
the developers they will very soon get
to their understanding on that and as
someone who in my
past rollers manage relationships with
suppliers and customers
once they know where you're going for
then plans will come forward
uh which will be a lot more accessible
than these ones
and i'll give you a couple of examples
of areas where we can't be stronger i
think second four says that there's one
room fully accessible on the ground
floor
fantastic and but it says that another
15 i think which could be
converted to accessibility if required
now
as a council we've adopted the social
model of disability which means we're
going to remove barriers to
um we're going to remove barriers to
disabled people section 24 almost says
well look
there are barriers here as a disabled
person you can remove them if you want
to
because it's built in and it just
doesn't feel it doesn't feel right
section nine on a race as a planning
meeting about 18 months ago i think
it talks about that there are
alternative facilities for disabled
people being available elsewhere in
trafford
so the fact that there's only one what
it's this
size today parting system is fine
because disabled people can go elsewhere
we would never say that about any other
protected characteristic we would never
say there's a building here where women
are not allowed to go but don't worry
about it because there's a building next
door where they can
we would be outraged and rightly so and
we should be
getting that level of uh outrage when we
say similar things about
disabled people um and it also fails to
recognize that
um disabled people are don't just
inhabit
um spaces they visit them
so you've got it's we would never say to
a to a non-disabled person you can't
visit that
property because of of some
characteristics you've got yet we're
saying to the the
the people who live in this building you
can't have
you can't have disabled friends i'll
fail finish their chair i'll be saying
again no
no no no calls for a big debate it's
just some points to make on the
on the um on the developments so thank
you chair thank you councillor
councillor bigby your
hand is indicating yes thanks just
briefly i'll try not to repeat what's
being said um
i i don't share council of ministers
excitement over this i think it's uh
i wouldn't be excited if it was a
redevelopment because
it's been intimated it's not a very
attractive building
i can really understand the concerns of
residents and
those expressed by councillor german i
think in any neighborhood
if residents got a rumor or heard
that 66 students were about to descend
on the area there would be concern but i
took
a great deal of comfort from reading the
report of miss coley
saying there's security
um so there will be supervision so
that the supervision and security um
was my main concern but um that was all
thank you councillor big b and the
application has been proposed and
seconded that
um that we support um officer
recommendation
this evening i mean i i actually find
myself um
[Music]
in dangerous agreement with council
accordingly i suppose i agree agree with
almost everything that he said this
evening on this application
and one thing i i would say is that
i don't think i'm concerned about the
application i'm just perhaps
a little bit nervous but i suppose for
us
um as a local authority we would always
find ourselves being a little bit
nervous given that this is the first
development of its type it's the first
um development that is solely student
accommodation
so you know this this is moving into the
unknown territory for what's less than
purpose
um as somebody who works in
tenancy management and tenancy
enforcement i do worry a little bit
about
quite how enforceable the condition in a
tendency agreement around
having access to a car and parking is
uh and i suppose i'm a little bit
concerned that down the line
down the line we might find ourselves
traffic problems that perhaps we can't
correct
um however i suppose we'll have to cross
that bridge when we come to it
i was surprised myself that we didn't
see more residents objecting to this
application the number of uh
representations is not the high i was
expecting
that to be popular opposition to this
and there just isn't so
perhaps that's um we can find the issue
wins in that
um the other thing i was gonna say is
mentioned in the debate that
you know we should probably welcome the
um
this is a self-contained site of student
accommodation i mean that
i was a postgraduate student in
battlefield and i can tell you i'd much
rather take
um a purpose-specific
site of accommodation such as what that
being proposed in the application than
to find the house upon house uh
and a community of terrorist housing
suddenly starts
getting taken over and um you end up
with
all of the um community confrontations
that come with it so
nervous is how i describe myself
slightly nervous
maybe but i think i will be supporting
the application this evening
if for no other reason that there is no
planning reason to oppose it as it
stands
um now the application has been proposed
and seconded as a stuff before i think
it's
time for us to move to the vote and as
such help the
call members as you're appearing on my
screen and counselor proctor
agree officer recommendation to grant
thank you councillor
councillor joao i also agree with his
officer a
recommendation to grant's thanksgiving
thank you councillor councilman rigby
i agree with your officer's
recommendations thank you councillor
councillor hartley
thank you chair i agree officer
recommendation to grant thank you thank
you councillor councilman minis
39 with office correct recommendation to
grant thank you
thank you councillor councillor morgan
agree in line with officer
recommendations to grant chair thank you
councillor councillor win stanley
uh disagree with officer's
recommendation chair thank you
thank you councillor councillor
coordinate uh support officer's
recommendation to glenn
thank you councillor councillor holden
support the recommendation to grant
thank you councillor councillor dr
barclay have you joined us
midway through this item yeah i joined
midway through
thank you um so i met that
one member voting against two two from
nine voting in favor with my vote in
favor
also that application is approved um
next item i will turn to is
five pinewood which you can find on page
168 of the committee report
um before we hear them either with the
speakers
um the item will be introduced by mr day
uh thank you chairman i think um mr
pearson is just going to
share the plans um yep
okay yeah um this application
uh has been reported to the planning and
development management committee as it's
been called in by councillor holden
on the grounds of impact on visual and
residential immunity
by reason of scale and parking concerns
um the application relates to a
two-story link detached dwelling house
which is located on the western side of
pinewood which is a small cul-de-sac
in sale um the dwellings on pine would
each benefit from an original
single-story flat roof garage adjacent
to the property
um the property also has an existing
single-story front porch
the layout of the properties are
staggered with the application property
set further back then number three
and set further forward than number
seven as you can see on the
location plan there the application
proposes two separate single story rear
extensions
to the rear of the main dwelling and to
the rear of the existing garage
respectively
and the single story front extension
in front of the garage the single story
rear extension to the main dwelling
would project three meters
from the existing rear elevation
adjacent to number seven pine wood
the rear extension to the garage would
project 774
mil to the rear adjacent to number three
pine wood
the front extension would project one
meter to the front of existing garage
the proposed work could also include the
raising the height
of the roof of the garage in connection
with the conversion of this element into
living accommodation
the key issues to be considered relate
to design and residential immunity
an objection has been received from the
occupy one neighboring property
raising concerns regarding a number of
issues including amenity impacts
and parking officers consider that the
proposed extension would be acceptable
in terms of design
and visual amenity would have no
unacceptable impact on the residential
amenity of neighbouring properties
and would be acceptable in terms of
parking provision it's therefore
considered that the pros development
would comply with policy l7 of the core
strategy
and guidance in the mppf and it's
recommended that permission is granted
um there is an update in relation to
the objectives comments as reported in
the additional information reports
in that where this refers to sound
proofing
this should say that the objective is
informed that sound proof
plasterboarding
is inadequate rather than adequate
thank you chair
thank you mr day i understand that the
two people speaking against this
application um council holding holden
and ms al amir is there any preference
as to who speaks for us doing that
i've been asked
and then michelle will speak for us
wonderful counselor you have five
minutes thank you
thank you the most common cause of
concern
raised with me by residents over the
years
have involved neighbors extensions in
fact
my first plea to this committee many
years ago now
i misquoted jean-paul sartre by
explaining to them that hell
is other people's extensions not just
other people
in this case we have a 1970s estate with
a wide range of properties
including bungalows apartments town
houses
and a variety of property that i'd never
come across before
link detached which is what we have here
when these homes were designed and built
the use of a garage space
to provide separation without adding to
the footprint
gave all the advantages of separate
structures
where garage space is developed at a
stroke
although in most cases after weeks of
noise and other disruptions
during the building process the whole
becomes
semi-detached and all the perceived
advantages of
detachment are lost and this is really
one of the basis of the concerns
here we have a proposal began as a
study stroke guest room
has apparently morphed into additional
living space
for an extended family effectively
changing their house
from a three-bedroom property to one
with four bedrooms
and with the implications that this has
on the number of residents
and subsequently on parking
a four bedroom dwelling according to
spd3
requires a maximum of three off-road
parking spaces i think the off-road
aspect is important because although the
report says
there is apparently some scope for
parking on the street on pinewood
this estate which i understand that i
also live on although some considerable
distance away
has a major ongoing i caught an
irritation
rather than a problem of more cup
more cars than there are than
the layout reflects the level of
ownership that was called
now the situation where every street as
i just said
has on street parking the problem with
this particular street is that
that on street parking is at the end
of a small as it was described
cul-de-sac
where any old street parking will
interfere with the accessibility
of all the properties across the bottom
there is a document in spd4 described
as supplementary planning document
section 2 13 4 parking provision
and there are two sketches i've included
those sketches in my
written submission and you'll see
oh if you've had a chance to look at
that you'll see that the
one that's described as undesirable
is additional parking space and garages
alongside the neighboring property
rather than on the opposite side of the
building
and it is this neighboring property
which creates the problem
the wall into the garage is the wall of
the living room
of the house at number three at the
moment
that garage space provides privacy and
some insulation
this plan removes that
and the presence of initial door over
which you'll see on the new plans which
gives
access to the proposed garage conversion
without going into the house suggested
to all of us that what we're looking at
here is a separate
separate accommodation which we will be
used all the time
and will create noise and concern
finally i think we should
uh consider that one of the
recommendations
for any on submitting a planning
application
is to speak with the neighbor especially
when we have the infamous
party wall issue here we have a party
wall
here we have a neighbor who has now
consistently
refused to negotiate
or to engage with number three
and has expressed his
suggestion shall we say that he can do
what he likes
and although strictly these are not
100 planning applications implications
there is a major implication but what we
are looking at here
is a massive reduction in the quality of
life
of one particular resident to the
benefit of the mother
and so i'll just continue
or finish with one comment about
extensions
which you all know about an extension is
a wonderful
expression of ownership you don't have
to look at it
your neighbours do you live in it your
neighbors don't
i know that on the strict planning that
counselor you are at the time now
just wrap my referrals throw myself and
the resident number three on your
subjective considerations
thank you thank you councillor um
are you passing
yes i am can you hear me uh cam is on
mary um you have three minutes to speak
if you do everyone i'll just uh politely
request it
thank you thank you thank you good
evening everybody
i'd like to point out that i have never
complained
and i've always had a harmonious
relationship with five pinewood
this application has damaged this and
that
saddens me my issue is with the garage
extension mainly
the applicant mr richardson informed me
in detail of the proposed changes
and they have always intended to build a
flat
this highlighted the discrepancy in the
description on the plan
on the application because a guest room
study implies
occasional use and not the 24
7 full-on home containing a lounge
bathroom and bedroom for the applicant's
extended family to live in
i mean why not build above the proposed
first floor rear extension
why does the guest room need to be so
large
and require its own front door it is
because it is a separate accommodation
and not an occasional guest room
we have a small row of terraces on our
avenue on our houses on our avenue a
couple have converted their garage
but they're not extended or connected to
anyone's lounge or effect off
on-road parking and i'm informed by
those occupants that sound proof
plasterboarding is inadequate five
pinewoods garage utility room is
attached and runs a full length and
beyond of my lounge
and at present the garage acts as a
buffer for transmission of noise
now this buffer will be removed
i have concerns that planning conditions
whilst they are appreciated
can be misinterpreted and cause
additional
tension for me to deal with in the
future
the planning service decided that the
human rights act would
not be contravened quote in a balance
for both parties
but to view the imbalance please see
plan eight one five four
twenty where the applicants will have a
kitchen
stairwell downstairs bathroom plus a
hallway acting as a buffer to their
lounge from their family's flat
whereas my main living area is
immediately next to this flat
only separated by a single wall i would
maintain that that act is being
contravened and there is an imbalance
disturbance and noise will ruin the
enjoyment of my home
and quality of life causing distress
because i fear the tranquility i've
enjoyed for the past 27 years will be
disrupted
reduced noise is the reason i bought a
link detached house
and sadly mental health issues are a
hidden handicap and do not fit into the
planning services criteria and it's not
easy for me to have the public admit in
this forum that i suffer from anxiety
and stress
and my home the peace quiet it offers
within it
is my sanctuary when these belts become
too much
and i have to engage coping strategies
and i respectfully request
this application is denied thank you ms
alameri thank you for being with us this
evening
um there are no other um
speakers to this application are there
any members looking to open the
discussion to this item
council and menace you've indicated
thank you chair i just really want to
thank both speakers to be honest
um i i'm a great fan of neighbours
um getting along with each other and
when you want
and to do an alteration to your house to
actually speak to your neighbor ideally
before
you um actually put an application in to
make sure that everybody
and have an open discussion and this
sadly obviously hasn't gone
uh in the right way for this um i can
understand entirely
what the neighbours concerns are here
we have a garage it's a single brick
wall
type of dwelling and we're talking about
that is going to be right next to
um this lady if she's got used to this
is a granny flat let's all be honest
about
it right the garage being extended at
both ends
and joined up to the main uh to the
porch part of the main dwelling
it's it's a granny flat and it is
basically somebody's going to live in
there
all the time it's not a it's not an
occasional use room
and i think this is something we need to
have a look at there are
houses on my my my road we have
10 houses where we they're semi-detached
but many of the houses are joined by
garages
they can't have extensions on top of
their garages because it would have a
harrow terracing
effect we need to consider what the
houses were designed for in the original
place
and what these changes if we are going
to approve them
would be i personally am going to be
voting against because i don't think
that this is a fair
way of going about doing things
and so i personally will be going
against but i'm happy to
to hear the rest of the discussion thank
you very much
thank you councillor councillor morgan
um thank you chair um i'm
really i'm not really sure how to go on
this which is
unusual when i i i probably came
expecting to vote in line with officer
recommendations but
um listen to the two objectives
including council holden
um i've really started to really
reassess this um
i'm not really very keen to understand
it on the the way that these
developments happen dears mean in terms
of effect we get terrorist streets us
meaning
completely against what the original
plan of this
the um when these develop these
estates were built um and i really can't
understand the objection on that but
that is the situation we're in and it
would not be the first situation where
effectively a detached house has become
semi-detached
um but i do appreciate the parking point
and i mean i just was reassessing
because i just went to the to the street
a few weeks ago because we had the
delayed
delayed meeting and you can see the
prompt parking problems just from the
google street view
um where the parking is
taking over the the pavement and i do
really see
um council holden's point about on spd3
that
this street is not designed for
on-street parking
um it is to just about lanes which means
people are
pavement parking which i'm sure all of
the councillors on this committee can
um come is there's been an issue just i
mean it gets raised by me
um but here i can you there is no way if
a
car is parked on pavement you can walk
on it um
there's it's not a it's not a wide
street it's a narrow street because
these roads were never designed for
this level um so i really am i i'll be
really interested in what other
counselors have to say because i really
do have a um a worry about the parking
situation on that
and there should be three parking spaces
here
um and there isn't um the documentation
says there will be
two spaces and then there will be
utilized on on street parking well there
isn't on-street parking in my books
um and this road was not designed for
the number of cars that
that um now it now has and we're
proposing to add
more onto it um so yeah i've really got
real concerns on parking
and um i'm not i have to be honest i've
not decided how i'm going to vote on
this
um but i'm really interested in what
other members have to say
thank you councillor morgan and
councillor jerome
oh in fact beforehand sorry sorry
counselor
um mr day has uh requested to just
provide some clarification on a couple
of points that have been raised
yeah thank you chairman um yeah just
just one of two points really um
obviously
um in in terms of the the issue about
the property being linked detached
it's important to bear in mind that the
the garage is already partially
converted into
a utility room and if they
if the proposal didn't include
extensions
to the property there would be no
restriction on it being converted
to living accommodation that there is no
nothing to prevent that that wouldn't be
a change of use
secondly the additional information
report does include a condition
for the avoidance of doubt that the
accommodation
would be um occupied
as ancillary accommodation to the
existing property
um not not as a separate residential
unit although it's obviously
quite modest anyway um
and thirdly in terms of parking
provision um as as i mentioned
previously the garage um has already
been partially converted so it doesn't
provide a parking space
at the moment there would still be two
parking spaces
that meet the council's dimensions on
the driveway
um it may be worth
looking further at the the photographs
that were
on the slideshow again if if necessary
um there are actually
at least three three cars parked on the
driveway
at the moment though i appreciate one of
those is um
overhanging onto the pavement but um
in reality that the parking situation
wouldn't really be any different there
would be one additional bedroom
um which does generate an additional
parking space but um
officers do not consider that there
would be any significant
um detrimental impact in terms of
parking
thank you thank you mr dana councillor
jeremy
i was going to say that this can't be
too far off being permitted development
um i i went to look at this property and
i couldn't quite see the problems that
councillor holden
has mentioned on the impact on visual
immunity by scale
um i don't think it would be too out of
place in in the in the in the street
scene at all
and as the report suggests the parking
issues
are dealt with um and there is other
space along the road if you go further
away from the house for
parking um so i didn't see parking as a
problem um so i'm i'm happy to propose
that we
um approve this uh development
um i do synthesize with the objectives i
always do because i know it's not easy
but there are um ways of dealing with
noise issues beyond
uh planning in fact they aren't really
planning issues at all
um but i do sympathise with the resident
on that but i can't see any problem with
this development
um so i'm happy to approve it
thanks joe thank you councillor and
council accordingly
uh thanks chair uh i'm going to be
prepared to second uh
councillor jerome's um motion um
yeah i've got i've got i do have some
reservations i do think um
it will turn into a granny flat and what
have you
but essentially planning is silent on a
lot of those issues as councillor jerome
said i think
it's we're going to struggle to uh
oppose it we're going to have to come up
with some
planning reasons and that so far i
haven't heard a planning reason to
oppose and i think
that tells me i've got to support um
actually accepting the uh planning
application
uh thanks sure so i second it
thank you councillor totally take on
board what you've said there in
terms of the worry would be that
if we don't have a strong reason it
would just be overturned
at appeal with committee to turn this
now now
councillor hartley you've indicated
thank you jay yeah it's just really to
follow up on that point i think i was
quite
torn on this one uh at the start of the
discussion um the advice from from mr
dare is
really useful i was concerned the report
didn't address the
the effect on immunity by by the
conversion but it's
it's really useful advice to know that
you know that would be
permitted development i do i do have
sympathy with with the neighbor and with
counselor holden's um remarks because uh
i do
think that that conversion will impact
on on amenity but um but i don't think
that's a matter we can
take account of because of the um the
permitted development
rights which which could be used anyway
um
so i think i think picking up where the
council accordingly left
left off um you know while while i do
have sympathy with
with those um with those objections i
don't think there is a
planning reason to to refuse this
application um
i think the um you know the conversion
of use would be permitted development
right so it really just comes down to
the parking which other people have have
talked about and the guidance is for a
you know a maximum number of parking
spaces so
um so there doesn't have to be three
off-road parking spaces
i agree with what councilman morgan said
you know this is an estate where
it was probably never envisaged that
they would be on street uh
parking and it will be much better if it
was a you know a wide road with with
with ample room for for on street
parking but
if we're getting down to you know we're
potentially thinking of turning this
application down
because of that you know one parking
space issue i really don't think that is
a sufficient reason to um
to refuse permission and and uh it
wouldn't be a strong reason to do that
and probably make us vulnerable on
appeal
as you as you mentioned chair so i i
would support council accordingly some
motion to agree with the office of
recommendation thank you chair
thank you councillor um it has now been
proposed and seconded
that uh the application be approved in
line with the opposite recommendation
are there any other members looking to
speak
not as far as i can tell um
as such i think it's appropriate for us
to just move to the vote now
and cancel the proxy uh some
some concerns but i can't really see any
reasonable planning reasons to
reject this application so agree with
officer recommendations
in that case counselor
mission to grant thanks joe thank you
councillor councillor hartley
thank you i agree with officer
recommendation to grant thank you thank
you
councillor council and minis i'm voting
against offer
officer recommendation thank you thank
you councillor
councillor morgan
hi looks in the chair but um votes in
line with officer recommendations
thank you councillor castleman stanley
eckland councilman
councilman morgan sentiments but uh
approve in line with officer
recommendations
thank you councillor council accordingly
uh
support officers recommendations to
glenn thank you councillor councillor
bigby support officers recommendations
to grant
thank you councillor and
councillor dr barclay support officer's
recommendation to grant thank you
councillor
i will also vote in language officer
recommendation to grant which is
i think that's nine to one uh vote
against
that application is approved
um final item this evening is
42 church road and council of german i
can see you've joined
the the call if you were waiting for
the item in your ward it has already
been determined it's been heard that
application
just to let you know okay that's fine
thank you
thank you yeah um 42 church vote which
can be found on
page 205 if the committee report will
have an officer
introduction from mr deck
thank you chairman um yeah
um this application has been reported
to the planning development management
committee as it's been called in
by councillor procter um on the grounds
that the proposal would not be an
over-dominant form of development
and would not have a detrimental impact
on the character or visual appearance of
the street scene
um the application property is a
two-story semi-detached dwelling house
which is located on the northwestern uh
corner
um of the junction of church road and
warmly grove
as you can see on the location plan
there
on the opposite side of warmly grove
there is an electricity substation
which is surrounded by a privet hedge
with trees
on the site frontage
the eastern side elevation of the
existing property is approximately
aligned
with the main two story eastern side
elevations of numbers one and two
uh chatwind avenue and number one
shanklin avenue to the north
the application proposes a two-story
side extension which would be 3.8 meters
in width
and would span almost the full width of
the gap between the existing side
elevation
and the side boundary retaining between
0.15 meters and 0.3 meters
to the boundary with walnsley grove
the extension would provide a family
room utility room and rear store area
a ground floor and a fourth bedroom with
an ensuite
to its rear first floor level
there are some photographs on on the
slides which well you can see
the extension there on the um
the existing and proposed elevations and
layouts and then there are some
photographs which show
the view from church road and also that
there from church road
um the application property on on the
right there
um and also um looking back
up uh warmly grove towards church road
[Music]
and looking towards the side of the the
property from
the corner of the junction the key issue
is the impact on the visual immunity and
spaciousness of the street scene
no representations have been received
from the occupiers of neighboring
properties
officers consider that the proposed
development would result in a
disproportionate and cramped form of
development
that would be over dominant and out of
keeping with the spacious character of
the area
and would therefore have a detrimental
impact on the visual appearance of the
street scene
the application is therefore recommended
for refusal thank you chairman
thank you mr day um counselor property
you called this application into
committee um
you've got five minutes to speak yes
okay thank you chair um
just to mention at first that the
applicant couldn't miss potter was also
going to
speak this afternoon against the office
of recommendation
but she's unable to due to another
commitment
so i just wanted to sort of mention that
the reason for my calling and opposition
to the recommendations to refuse
is outline extensively in the report
and they would ask that committee
consider these comments which can be
seen on page 208
and come to the same conclusion as me
that this proposal should be granted
as you will see the application is for
the erection of a two-story side
extension
to create a badly needed family room
utility
and restore area on the ground floor
with a fourth bedroom
and ensuite to the rear of the first
floor
any committee members who have visited
the site will see the properties
situated
in a corner plot at the junction of
church road and onesie grove
the only property that could potentially
be realistically impacted negatively by
this development
would be that directly to the rear
number one checkman avenue
the officer report however concludes
that there will be no under overlooking
impact
on that property the report also
concludes that due to the
location of proposed development in
relation to other dwellings
there will be known duly negative impact
on other properties
i agree with both these conclusions and
it's quite telling that no
representations from neighbors have been
received
as committee members would be fully
aware that if neighbors have any
concerns whatsoever
about it they're always very eager to
make negative comments
as we've seen in many committee meetings
clearly
in this case they have no concerns and
are happy to go ahead
i know that miss potter has talked
extensive to her neighbors about her
plans
i understand that they are also also all
very supportive
the office of reason for refusal however
centers on the assertion that the
proposed plans
result in a disproportionate and cramped
form of development
that will be over dominant and out of
keeping with the space nature of the
area
the conclusion of a definite impact on
the character and visual appearance on
the street scene
and knee bar areas as you can see myself
the applicant and neighbors directx
exert this
and it will this will be the case and
i've previously outlined in my reasoning
information given to the calling which
you can see on page 208
just some information i'll just run
through that again
there will be no impact on the
prevailing spacious feel of the area as
the trees and hedge
on the opposite side of the road allow a
soft to spacious character
the trees and hedge are practically on
the boundary of the plot and so don't do
not diminish the spacious nature of the
site
the roof ridge and extension will be
lower than existing trees
there will be also be no inevitable
impact upon the neighboring properties
a result of the proposed extension which
i've already mentioned
two neighbouring properties on church
road have had the same extension
and a property three doors away has a
single story with a lean to over
corner properties at wendover road and
beach avenue on the same side of the
side of their junction as a applicant's
property
are higher buildings and closer to the
boundary the proposed extension is
therefore very aligned
to the character of the area and have no
a negative
impact spd4 3.3.2 allows for each case
to be considered individually
and i would request that the specific
nature of this locality is taken into
account
also just for clarity i do accept that
the
development would not exactly match the
strict conditions of spd4
which in actual realistic terms it would
have none of or very little
definitional effect on the prevailing
character of the street scene of the
area
or indeed church road itself in
conclusion
i do hope that the committee can take a
common sense approach to this
development
and overturn the officer recommendations
refuse the applicant desperately needs
the extra space for a family and it
would
not badly affect her neighbors in any
significant way
it has the support of residents within a
local vicinity and will be
consistent with other similar extensions
that have already been built
so it can be confident in saying that it
would not create a cramped aspect or
impact
on the street scene um in line with my
declaration previously i won't
participate in
the discussion of the committee and i
will not vote
thank you chair thank you councillor
proctor um
council according that you've indicated
you'd like to speak
i suspect it will be a thanks chair i
suspect there'll be a bit of a debate
over this one
my my problem with sbd4 is
that i think the officers have adhered
to it completely correctly
i think in the past we've been flexible
over some
um corner properties um
because they're being untypical
my problem with this application is it's
absolutely typical
if there's nothing exceptional about
this as a corner property
so in terms of moving it
outside the line of the neighbouring two
properties
i don't see what is
special about this and it feels to me
that either we decide that um
some of the planning guidance is wrong
in which case that that that that is
fair enough when we change the planning
guidance but if we're expecting planning
officers
to adhere to guidance and there's
nothing exceptional about this
i have a problem with keep turning these
against the
if there's nothing exceptional sometimes
there will be something exceptional but
i'm really struggling with this one
it's a straightforward corner property
on a straightforward
90 degree angle and a straightforward
straight behind it
so i'm going to propose that we accept
the officers recommendation
emotionally partly mainly because
they've
applied the rules absolutely right uh
and i don't see how i can go against
them
and and for that reason but i suspect i
won't be the last voice on this one
thank you council called in may and i
know exactly what applications you're
thinking on the
committee's previous as well um
councillor
joe jerome think um uh
councillor proctor mentioned a good
point and i think it kind of rebuts what
council accordingly has just said
spd4 3.3.2
it does allow for each case to be
considered individually
um so that that is quite important and i
i think it is a tough one when we
um when officers recommend refusal this
is something as a committee we should
take seriously
we have to try and be consistent as
council accordingly says but also
apply the guidelines fairly and this is
a slightly difficult decision
um but spd 4.3.32 does say we should
look at them individually
i don't think there will be any negative
impact upon neighbouring properties and
many of them have had similar extensions
which all
which are almost joining each other in
some cases
um and i don't think the development
would have any detrimental impact on the
prevailing character or street scene of
the area
i think again going to the location
and looking around i don't think it
actually would and the report does
indicate that one shep wind avenue
um is still 10.1 metres boundary it's
still intact
so there'll be no undue overbearing or
overshadowing impact according to the
report
but there are some arguments against i
think
you know it's two meter boundary in spd4
guidance for corner plots
but this is two floors and it comes
within 0.15 meters
of the fence so they are kind of taking
this right up to the limit and going
beyond what um the guidance says and i
think
if you do stand on walmsley grove the
spaciousness
the spaciousness as the report says will
be affected
um so i think we should take that
seriously but i think balancing up the
arguments
i'm inclined to go towards um
against officer recommendation on this
application and i
i do take the arguments of counsellor
proctor and i i think
i probably will join council accordingly
in
um voting against officer recommendation
i just wanted to make one small
point before i finished um if you go on
to the other side of the
the road on walmsley grove it's lined
with nice trees in
in the grass verge but the trees for
some reason seem to have been decimated
on the verge
just outside of this this house and i'm
just wondering whether that could be
part of the condition that
as part of the planning application they
were to contribute to
adopt a tree outside on onto the grass
verge to
to kind of help with the impact um but
that's it for me thanks joe
thank you councillor we'll return to
your query about the um
potential to other conditions now
councilman winston
uh thank you chair um
i had to do a double take when i saw
this address i used to i used to live on
wendover road i used to drive past this
block of houses every day and i was
quite i was quite surprised i found out
that that particular house didn't
already have an extension
because the whole of the um the whole of
the block there
while it's not in keeping with the
character of the the other side of
church road which is which is very 19th
century it's all modern
semi-detached houses with tasteful
extensions on them
and when i went to see the uh
to to refresh my memory as to where the
sites actually looked
i can't agree with all the
representations which
um which counselor proctor made
the the proposed exchange will
be completely in character with that
part of
with that part of church road i don't
think he'll be
uh disproportionately cramped and i
don't think even if you look at the
street scenes going down warms the road
and back out onto church
i think he'll make absolutely negligible
difference
and for what always swings me as well
when i when i
even with the decisions which i find
more difficult than this one is
look at what the residents have said the
residents are epic
and i so i don't i think there will be
no um
it won't be disreported it won't be
cramped so i will be voting
uh to go against officer's
recommendation thank you chair
thank you councillor councillor hartley
thank you chair i'm a bit torn on this
one still i have to say i mean i think
council accordingly it sort of
illustrated the
sort of quandary in with this quite well
in that um although i probably disagree
with his conclusion i think
the the so so the extension clearly
isn't in accordance with the spd4
guidelines in it in a number of ways you
know the closeness to the boundary the
the
the size and scale of the extension um
so it clearly doesn't comply with those
spd4 guidelines
um but there are guidelines and we we
had the same issue on a
on an application during the first part
of this meeting where we you know we had
a site in in sale which
you know which significantly exceeded
the um
the the distances for the rear
extensions it was in that case but we
were
sort of satisfied overall with you know
with the appearance and with the
and with the the impact that that
extension caused
so um so they are on a guidelines that's
my understanding of the
of the advice we had last last week and
actually um
i probably disagree with councillor win
stanley to a certain
extent in that um i do i do think this
is a a sensitive extension actually and
i actually think it's in
um it's it's more in keeping with the
original house
than probably the other extensions on
that row i think there's
four or six i think it's four semis that
you know the same sort of house
i think they've all had extensions and
all of them are
sort of in keeping with the original
house but they all stick out a bit as
obviously
an adam as obviously an extension
whereas this
is quite sympathetically dealing in
keeping with the original house
but um the re the reason it achieves
that is because
it doesn't have a subservient appearance
and you know the front elevation
isn't set back so those are all the
things in in in spd4 guidance about what
makes
an acceptable extension so i i think
it's a real challenge because
i think what i'm saying is i i don't i
don't have a particular problem with
with this extension i don't think it's
going to have a a significant impact on
the street scene the report concludes
there's no
impact on the immunity of neighbors and
there are there haven't been any
objections
um but but probably my problem is
is with is with the guidance in that
case both in terms of the distances and
and
and the appearance of extensions so
i'm probably at the moment thinking that
i will um
disagree with the office recommendation
um and and think we should probably
grant this but i do have some real
difficulty with it because i'm i think
in doing that i'm saying that um you
know i think the guidance on on
extensions
isn't isn't necessarily right but it you
know the the guidance is as it is for
the moment
so i'll stop there sure because uh i've
not come to a firm conclusion yet thank
you
thank you councillor and counselor rigby
yes chairman thank you very much indeed
um
i visited the site i know the area well
and
i really do um disagree with
a lot of what's being said because i
thoroughly agree with the officers
um the development i understand why
the applicant wishes to develop as many
people do
but by reason of its width height and
scale and massing and certainly going
right
up to the boundary for goodness sake
it's going to
give a cramped effect on a very spacious
boundary
to the detriment that um local residents
haven't raised an objection um
isn't a consideration of the planning
issue here
i really do have to disagree that
what's been said that the proposal would
not be over
dominant it would not have a detrimental
effect
on the character and visual appearance
of the street scene
of course it would it's going to be a
very large
development and i in my opinion
there's no balance i think officers are
100 right
thank you councillor no one else
indicating
to speak at person the position we find
ourselves in is that um
the application of the office of
recommendation
has been proposed by council accordingly
but not seconded and that there is no
countermotion um
are there any members who are happy to
second council accordingly
proposition
the proposition
um the application be declined in line
with uh
office of recommendation i'm prepared to
second that please
there has now been an uplink
i'm sorry council minute have you have
you indicated
apologies i've ever looked at that
is it okay to speak is that okay yeah
yeah sorry
all right okay okay that's right okay
thank you chair
um so what i was looking at is i was
torn says
i like the fact that they the um the
applicants have spoken to the neighbors
and everybody's on board and that's
i'm all a fan of that the problem i have
is it's a double story and it's right up
to the boundary
and there's like 15 centimeters between
it and the boundary
and because i think it's on because i
think it's on a corner because i know a
lot of the other
houses along there have had similar
sorts of extensions
and i can understand that you know
others have had it and
almost why can't a corner have it too
but because it's a corner
you have a road going down the side and
it does form a different
corners are a bit different in some ways
you get you get more land you get more
um freedom with the development and
sometimes it
actually goes the other way i think my
issue with this is it goes right
up to the boundary um and it's a double
story if it were a single story
going up maybe a little bit in
from the boundary i'd probably be all in
favor of it but it's not it's a double
story and it's going right up to the
boundary so
i think the officers have got this right
and i'll be voting against thank you
as in along along along with the
officer's recommendation thank you
thank you councillor um it has now been
proposed and seconded that we
support officer recommendation to refuse
permission this evening
i i think everybody's a
views on the record now we we've had a
relatively robust discussion about this
and i think it is what it is and i take
on board what everybody said about spd4
and also about um the discretionary
nature of some of the aspects of
sbd4 but i think it's best that we move
to the vote now so
one three members as they appear on the
screen counselor proctor
i'm not participating chair oh of course
uh councillor joanne i think i've
actually changed my mind chair
and i i will vote in support of the
recommendation to refuse
thank you councillor councillor hartley
you chair yeah really useful debate
actually i think my problem is
it's potentially more with the guidance
um so i i think i also agree with the
officer recommendation to um to refuse
permission on this one i'm afraid
thank you
voting we're in line with officer
recommendation to refuse thank you
thank you councillor councillor morgan
um i agree with officer recommendations
to refuse chair
thank you councillor councillor stanley
uh no i did a really useful debate but i
i i remain persuaded that um i'm going
to vote against the officer
recommendation to refuse
thank you councillor councillor
accordingly
i can't believe i'm mute
sorry yes i think a really useful debate
um
but i i stick with the uh supporting the
office
recommendation thank you councillor
support the officer's recommendation
thank you
councillor councillor holden support the
recommendation to refuse thank you
councillor councillor dr berkley
i support the officer recommendation to
refuse
thank you counselor and i'll also vote
in line with
count uh with officer recommendation
which i think makes it
nine in favor of officer recommendation
one against that
application is refused um that concludes
the business of the meeting this evening
i think